you know I told him like y'all I need
y'all to rap he's like yo I want to rap
over something that is that has got
Tampa rockin so thank those channels my
dude famous kid brick man I'll layer
this the hottest record in the club out
here in sample right now minutes that
hate to see we bout to have my dude go
in Troy Ave young Leto this exclusive
only Ready Set Radio bootleg cab Troy
Ave tell them what you talked about my G
will be tell them that no venue checking
like you know it you know this number
one independent label Troy future let's
go embed it like Jersey I got this
glowing glove in that kitchen made it
all with my voice that's why I'm shining
guarding this with me blue fibers a
flippy I am to fly no dippy Oliver
[__] [__] with me I need bad [__]
so we don't take boy in bed like Mike
Jersey I got this glowing Glove and Ned
kitchen look made it oh my wrist
it's why I'm shining grinding this ready
uh-huh five Birds egg flippy I am to fly
oh geez I'm from a small block you can't
ride through you get a mac in your
window no drive-through on five five but
that chopper like 5 to 100 shots I can
make sure it for Tatsu I put a price on
your head [__] about you I get you hit
by your homies tend to buy you I ain't a
street fighter I've no ryu and some heat
bio-bullets a fry you
I'm [__] thuggin designing [__] I mean
[__] Sam [__] but I'm trying to quit
when they threatened in the llama spit
you heard me I said the llama spit bang
what can I say I'm just the young Villa
Gesell [__] talk [__] out we just
killed a chef I said Lou young real
[__] Beasley free my lord [__] going
bad like my Jersey I got this glowing
glove and a catchy hook song made it oh
look my racy it's why I'm signing
grinding this breaking the hook on a
spot of birds a flipper to fly
very bad [__] you shall we don't tip
uh-huh
boy and bad like Mike Jesse I got this
glowing glove and that kid she made it
all of my wrists see that's why I'm
shutting got in that whipping barbers a
foot finish making them to fly no dope
one truck
the real ones [__] with me no the bad
bet you sorry them take some huh doing
good ripping wood I'm switching lanes
switch games let it change watching
rings got it all old le cane Oh been a
honey since a cane
yeah Nikki can you say the same what
[__] lame I give him pain hit his
chest the hit his brain man sling who
deeply I don't know
I said pain and sham Chris damn my wrist
Rollie duster no time for bitching all
my time is spent out getting chips their
man they see me getting rich huh show ya
EBS be MMC and YC ya playin bad like
Mike jesse is glowing
loving it uh-huh I made it off my wrist
tipper I'm shining gun in this bum huh
Bobby are you to fly no dippy all the
real ones [__]
I need these bad shows or show me
titties boy man like Mike Jesse I got
this glowing glove in that kitchen wait
a swag shotgun in this with you baby are
you to fly no Debbie
ready [__] [__] with me no a bad
[__] show me they titties show them
young leader on the spot
sure yes getting got ya Rolex put it
clap yeah [__] I cannot be stopped
huh only stop and God right keep the
night I don't know the fight uh-huh no
I'm lying but if you front you dying
from bullets hot your wax is frying no
ass is fine like you in the chat I like
the [__] with the real long hair
yeah I like the [__] with the real
derriere is like but buses we do not
care we don't care we're psyched you
down get the work we break it down up
getting exploded you're shaking down off
BSB we run the town or any town or we
run a city these hoes [__] they say
we pretty here [__] I am old mixing huh
in the kitchen I got whippy we're
straight cook crack [__] yeah come see
me I'm that [__] [__] show ya Doughboy
congratulations to my Detroit man I know
you just had a baby shower last night
ladies if you out there and you're
trying to get bang a baby
is the bank when that baby shower hit
the ground and [__] call me so what
did you do last night
so none of your business